My name is professor Michio Kaku.
I'm a professor of theoretical physics
at the City University of New York and I
specialize in is something called string
theory.
I'm a physicist and some people asked me
the question,
what has physics done for me lately?
I mean,
do I get better colored television?
Do I get better Internet reception with
physics?
And the answer is yes.
Is he physics?
Is that the very foundation of matter
and energy?
We physicists invented the laser beam.
We invented the transistor.
We helped to create the first computer.
We helped to construct the internet.
We rode the world wide web.
In addition,
we also helped to invent television,
radio radar microwave's,
not to mention MRI scans,
pet scansx,
rays.
In other words,
almost everything you see in your living
room,
almost everything you see in a modern
hospital at some point or other can be
traced to a physicist.
Now,
I got interested in physics when I was a
child when I was eight.
A great scientist had just died.
I still remember my elementary school
teacher coming into the room and
announcing that the greatest scientist
of our era has just passed away and that
day every newspaper published a picture
of his desk,
the desk of Albert Einstein,
and the caption said,
I'll never forget the unfinished
manuscript of the greatest work of the
greatest scientists of our time.
And I said to myself,
why couldn't he finish it?
I mean,
what's so hard?
It's a homework problem,
right?
Why didn't he ask his mother?
Why can't he finish this problem?
So as a child of eight,
I decided to find out what was this
problem?
Years later,
I began to realize that it was the
theory of everything that unified field
theory,
an equation that would summarize all the
physical forces in the universe and
equation like e equals MC squared.
That equation is half an inch long and
that equation unlocks the secrets of the
stars.
Why do this star is shy?
Why does the Galaxy light up?
Why do we have energy on the earth?
But then there was another thing that
happened to me when I was around eight
years old.
I got hooked on the Saturday morning tv
shows in particular Flash Gordon and I
was hooked.
I made every Saturday morning watching
programs about alien from outer space,
stars,
ships,
ray guns in visibility,
shields,
cities in the sky.
That was me,
but after a few years I began to notice
something.
First of all,
I began to notice that,
well,
I didn't have blond hair and blue eyes.
I didn't have muscles like Flash Gordon,
but it was a scientist who made this
series work.
In particular,
a physicist.
He was the one who discovered the
Reagan,
the star ships.
He was the one who created the
invisibility shield,
and then I realized something else.
If you want to understand the future,
you have to understand physics.
Physics is at the foundation of all the
Gadgetry,
the wizardry,
all the marvels of the technological
age.
All of it can be traced to the work of a
physicist.
Most of science fiction is in fact well
within the laws of physics,
but possible within maybe 100 years,
and then we have impossibilities that
may take a thousand years or more.
That includes time travel,
warp drive,
higher dimensions,
portals through space and time,
stargates wormholes.
You know,
if you were to meet your great
grandparents of the year 1900,
they were dirt farmers back then.
They didn't live much beyond the age of
40 on average,
long distance communication in the year
1900 was yelling at your neighbor and
yet if they could see you now with ipads
and ipods and satellites and gps and
laser beams,
how would they view you?
They will view you as a wizard or
sourcer.
However,
if we can now meet our grandkids of the
year 2100,
how would we viewed them?
We would view them as gods like in Greek
mythology.
Zeus could control objects around him by
pure thought,
materialized objects just by thinking
and their perks being a Greek God.
Venus had a perfect body,
a timeless body,
and we are beginning now to unravel the
genetics at the molecular level of the
aging process.
And then Apollo.
He had a chariot that he could write
across the heavens.
We will finally have that flying car
that we've always wanted to have in our
garage.
By the year 2100,
we will have the power of the gods.
To Paraphrase Arthur,
c dot Clarke,
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from divinity.
So let's now begin our story.
The history of physics is the history of
modern civilization.
Before Isaac Newton,
before Galileo,
we were shrouded with the mysteries of
superstition.
People believed in all sorts of
different kinds of spirits and demons.
What made the planets move?
Why you do things,
interact with other things.
It was a mystery.
So back in the Middle Ages,
for example,
uh,
people read the works of Aristotle and
Aristotle as the question,
why do objects move toward the earth?
And that's because he said,
objects yearn,
yearn to be united with the earth.
And why do object slow down when you put
them in motion?
Objects in motion slow down because they
get tired.
These are the works of Aristotle,
which held sway for almost 2000 years
until the beginning of modern physics
with Galileo and Isaac Newton.
When the ancients looked at the sky,
the sky was full of mystery and wonder.
And in the year 10,
66,
the most important date on the British
calendar,
there was a comment,
a comment would sailed over the
battlefield of hastings.
It frightened the troops of King Harold
and a young man from Normandy swept into
England and defeated King Harold at the
battle of hastings creating the modern
British monarchy.
But the question is,
where did the comment come from?
What was this comment that mysteriously
pave the way for the coming of the
British monarchy?
Well,
believe it or not,
that same comment,
the very same comment that initiated the
British monarchy sailed over London once
again in 16,
82 this time,
everyone was asking the question,
where do comments come from?
Do they signal the death of the king?
Why do we have messengers from the
heavens in the sky?
Well,
one man dare to penetrate the secrets of
comments.
And that was Isaac Newton.
In fact,
when Isaac Newton was only 23 years old,
he stumbled upon the universal force of
gravitation.
According to one story,
he was walking on his estate and Wills
Thorpe,
and he saw an apple fall.
And then Isaac Newton saw the moon and
then he asked the key question which
help to unlock the heavens if apples
does the moon also fall.
And the answer was yes.
And that answer overturn thousands of
years of mystery and speculation about
the emotions of the heavens.
The moon is in free fall,
just like an apple.
The moon is constantly falling toward
the earth.
It doesn't hit the earth because it
spins around the earth and the earth is
round,
but it's acting under a force of force
of gravity.
So Newton immediately try to work out
the mathematics and he realized that the
mathematics of the 16 hundreds was not
sufficient to work out the motion of
falling moon.
So what did Isaac Newton do when he was
23 years old?
Not only did he stumble upon the force
of gravity,
but he also created calculus.
In fact,
he created calculus at the rate at which
you learn it when you're a freshman in
college.
And why did he create calculus?
To calculate the motion of a falling
moon?
The mathematics of his age was incapable
of calculating the trajectories of
objects moving under an inverse square
force field,
and that's what Isaac Newton did.
He worked out the motion of the moon and
then he realized that if he understands
the moon,
he also understands the motion of the
planets in the solar system,
and Isaac Newton invented a new
telescope.
It was the reflecting telescope,
and he was tracking the motion of this
comment.
Well,
it turns out that everyone was talking
about the comment,
including a rather wealthy Englishman by
the name of Edmund Halley.
So Edmund Halley being a wealthy
merchant,
decided to make a trip to Cambridge to
talk to England's illustrious
scientists,
Sir Isaac Newton.
Well,
Edmund Halley ask Newton.
What do you make of this comment?
No one understands comments.
There are mystery.
They've been fascinating people for
centuries,
for Millennia.
What are your thoughts?
And then I paraphrase,
but Isaac Newton said something like
this.
He said,
oh,
that's easy.
That comment is moving in a perfect
ellipse.
It's moving in an in an inverse square
force field.
I've been tracking it every day with my
reflecting telescope and the path of
that comment,
conform this to my mathematics.
Exactly,
and of course we don't know what Edmund
Haley's reaction was by paraphrase.
He must have said something like this.
For God's sake,
man,
why don't you publish the greatest work
in all of scientific history if correct
you have decoded the secret of the
stars,
the secret of the heavens.
Nobody understands where comments come
from,
and then Newton responded and said,
oh,
well,
it cost too much.
I mean,
I'm not a wealthy man.
It would cost too much to summarize this
calculus that I've invented and to work
out all the motion of the stars,
and then Haley must have said this,
Mr Newton,
I am a wealthy man.
I have made my fortune in commerce.
I will pay for the publication of the
greatest scientific work in any
language,
and it was praying Kimbia the
principles,
the mathematical principles that guide
the heavens.
Believe it or not,
this is perhaps one of the most
important works ever written by a human
being in the hundred thousand years
since we evolved from Africa.
Realize that this book sets into motion
of physics of the universe,
forces that control the motion of the
planets,
forces which can be calculated forces
which govern the motion of cannon balls,
rockets,
pebbles,
everything that moves,
moves according to the laws of motion
and the calculus of Sir Isaac Newton.
In fact,
even today when we launch our space
probes,
we don't use Einstein's equations.
They only apply when you get near the
speed of light or near a black hole.
We use Newton's laws of gravity.
They are so precise that when we shoot a
space probe right past the rings of
Saturn,
we use exactly the same equations that
Isaac Newton unrivaled in the 16
hundreds.
That's why being able to unravel the
secrets of the solar system complements
of the laws of motion of Isaac Newton.
So what Newton did was not only did he
set into motion the ability to calculate
planets,
he also set into motion a mechanic's
machines now operated upon well defined
laws.
Newton's three laws of motion.
The first law of motion says that
objects in motion stay in motion forever
unless acted upon by an outside force.
You see that in an ice skating rink,
you shoot the puck and it goes all the
way down forever,
unless acted upon by an outside force.
That's different from Aristotle's law of
motion.
Aristotle said objects in motion
eventually stop because they get tired.
The second law of Motion Says Force is
mass times acceleration,
and that equation made possible the
industrial
revolution,
steam,
locomotives,
factories,
machines,
all of it,
dude to the mechanics set into motion by
Isaac Newton's second law of motion for
us as equal to mass times acceleration.
And then Newton had a third law of
motion.
For every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction.
That's a law of rockets.
That's what we have rockets that can
assailant the artist space.
So the lesson here is when scientists
unraveled the first force of the
universe,
gravity that set into motion,
the industrial revolution,
a which toppled the kings and Queens of
Europe,
which this place feudalism,
ushering in the modern age,
all because a 23 year old gentleman
looked up and asked the question,
does the moon also fall?
You know,
when I was a kid growing up in
California,
I would see pictures of the empire state
building and I said to myself,
how could they possibly build such a big
building and not know that it's going to
fall?
Why doesn't it far?
They didn't build scale models of the
thing.
You couldn't have an empire state
building that big that tests whether
it's going to fall in on how did they
know ahead of time that that building
wouldn't fall,
and the answer is Newton's laws of
motion.
In fact,
today I teach Newton's laws of motion
and you can actually calculate the
forces on every single brick of the
empire state building using Newton's
second law of Motion Force is mass times
acceleration
where Newton unraveled the force of
gravity.
That was the first force.
Now let's take a look at it,
a second force,
and even greater for us,
which has touched all of our lives,
and that is the electro magnetic force.
Ever since humans saw lightening bolts
light up the sky every since they were
terrified by the sound of thunder
they've been asking,
do the gods propelled lightning bolts
and create funder?
Are they angry at us?
Scientists began to realize that the
lightening bolts and the funder can be
duplicated on the earth,
that we can actually create many
lightening bolts using electricity,
but it wasn't until the 18 hundreds that
finally began to unlock the second great
forest,
which rules the universe,
the electromagnetic force,
Michael Faraday would give Christmas
lectures in London.
Fascinating everyone from adults to
children and he would demonstrate the
incredible properties of electricity.
Some people,
for example,
ask a simple question,
if you're in a car or an airplane,
you get hit by lightening bolt.
Why don't you all get electrocuted?
Why don't you all die?
Well,
fair to answer the question.
He would create a cage.
He would walk into the steel cage,
electrify it,
and he wouldn't get electrocuted at all.
That's called a faraday cage,
and every time you walk into a middle
structure,
you get shielded by this metal object.
Well,
but Michael Faraday did.
Was he helped to unleash the second
great revolution with something called
Faraday's law?
I'm moving wire in a magnetic field.
Has this electrons pushed,
creating an electrical current.
That simple idea unleashed the electric
revolution,
and that's why we have hydroelectric
generators.
Damn,
that can produce enormous amounts of
power.
That's why people build nuclear power
plants.
That's why we have electricity in this
room right now on a very small scale.
You use that in your bicycle.
When you put a bicycle lamp on your
bicycle,
the turning of the wheel spins a magnet.
The magnet then pushes electrons in a
wire,
and that's why electricity lights up in
your bicycle land.
So in other words,
electricity and magnetism where unified
into a single virus.
We once thought that electricity and
magnetism were separate.
Now we know they are in fact the same
force.
So if I'm moving magnet,
then create an electric field.
This means that a moving electric field
couldn't create a magnetic field,
but if they can create each other,
why can't they oscillate and create a
wave so that moving electric fields
create magnetic fields,
create electric fields,
create magnetic fields in an item to
create a wave?
Well,
around the time of the American civil
war,
a mathematical physicist James Clerk
Maxwell calculated using the work of
Farah day the velocity of this wave and
one of the greatest breakthroughs of all
time.
James Clerk Maxwell calculated the
velocity of this wave and found out it
was the velocity of light,
and then he made this incredible
discovery.
This is light.
That's what light is.
It doesn't by accident travel at the
speed of electricity,
it is light itself and the equations
were written down by James Clerk
Maxwell.
Unfortunately,
Michael Farady himself did not have a
formal education.
He could not put it into mathematical
form,
his own work.
James Clerk Maxwell was a theoretical
physicist like myself.
He wrote down the mathematical physics
of oscillating electric fields and
magnetic fields,
and they are a called Maxwell's
equations.
These equations have to be memorized by
every physicist in Grad school.
You cannot get your phd without
memorizing these equations.
Every engineer who deals with radar and
radio has to memorize these equations,
and so if you go to Berkeley where I got
my phd,
you can buy a t shirt which says in the
beginning God said the four dimensional
divergence of an anti symmetric second
rank tensor equals zero.
And there was like,
ladies and gentlemen,
this is the equation for light.
The consequences of the electromagnetic
revolution touch all of us.
This is a picture of the earth from
outer space.
Look at this picture,
Europe electrified.
You can actually see the fruits of all
of our efforts to create electricity,
to energize our lives in one picture.
Seeing the earth from outer space.
So let's now talk about how faraday and
Maxwell is,
where it touches your life as well.
This is the Internet.
The Internet is a simple byproduct of
the electromagnetic force and you can
see that where there is the internet,
there's prosperity,
there is science,
there's entertainment,
there's economic activity where there's
no internet,
there's poverty,
and in the future the Urjanet will be
miniaturized and it'll be placed in your
glasses.
Your glasses will recognize people's
faces and display their biography next
to the image as you talked to them,
and then when they speak Chinese to you,
your glasses will translate Chinese into
English and out subtitles right beneath
their image.
So in the future you will know exactly
who you are talking to without even
talking to them.
And this means that at a cocktail party,
if you're looking for a job but you
don't know who the heavy hitters are in
the future,
you will know exactly who to suck up to
in the future.
At chips,
all in cost a penny because we can
manufacture a tinier and tinier
transistors.
You will have ferritin's electromagnetic
forest inside your body.
This is a pill,
it has a chip in it.
The chip is smaller than an aspirin
pill.
It also has a TV camera and a magnet.
When you swallow it,
the magnet guides the camera taking
pictures of your stomach,
your intestines,
because we all know what middle aged men
feared the most colonoscopies,
and this gives new meaning for the
expression Intel inside.
Now,
let's talk about the next great forces
which ruled the universe.
We talked about gravity,
which allows us to calculate the motion
of the planets,
the mechanics created by Newton help to
unleash the industrial revolution.
Michael Faraday worked out the
electromagnetic force,
which gave us the wonders of the
electric age,
and now let's talk about the nuclear
age.
The stars and the Sun.
People have been fascinated by the sun.
Apollo was the God that strode across
the heavens and his fiery chariot,
but hey,
when you calculate how long coal or oil
will burn like the sun,
you realize that and just a few hundred
years,
the sun would burn to a Chris.
So what could possibly last for billions
of years?
There must be a new force on nuclear
forests.
Einstein and others helped to unravel
the secrets of the stars.
The nuclear forest comes in two types,
weak and strong.
The weak nuclear force governs
radioactive decay.
The strong nuclear force is one of the
strongest forces in the entire universe.
It's so strong.
It holds our protons together ever since
genesis the beginning of time.
The equation which allows for the
liberation of energy is Einstein's
famous equation e equals MC squared.
What Einstein showed was that the faster
you move,
the heavier you get,
so your weight is not a constant.
When you move very rapidly,
you get heavier.
Something which we measure every day in
the laboratory.
Now this means that the energy of motion
transformed into mass because you get
heavier.
Now listen carefully.
The faster you move,
the heavier you get,
which means the energy of motion.
He turns into Em.
Your mass and the relationship between
Enm is assembled.
It takes one second to write it down on
a sheet of paper.
It is exactly e equals Mc Square,
so the nuclear forests helped to explain
the secret of the sun,
but it also created a Pandora's box
because inside the nucleus of the Adam
are particles and when you smash these
particles,
what do you get?
More particles and when you smash them,
when do you get more particles?
In fact,
we are drowning in subatomic particles.
Hundreds,
thousands of subatomic particles.
Every time we smash atoms,
now we smash atoms using something
called Atom smashers or particle
accelerators.
I built my own particle accelerator when
I was in high school.
When I was in high school.
I went to my mom one day and I said,
mom,
can I have permission to build a two
point $3,
billion electron volt Beta particle
accelerator in the garage?
And my mom said,
sure,
why not?
And don't forget to take out the
garbage.
So I went to Westinghouse and as a high
school kid I asked for 400 pounds of
transformers steel.
I asked for 22 miles of copper wire
because I wanted to create a six
kilowatt,
10,000
gas magnetic field to energize my atom
smasher with 22 miles of copper wire.
How could you wind it?
We did it on the high school football
field.
I put 22 miles of copper wire and the
goalpost gave it to my mother.
She ran to the 50 yard line,
unraveling the spool of wire.
She gave it to my father who then ran to
the goalpost and we wound 22 miles of
copper wire on the high school football
field.
Well,
finally my atom smasher was ready.
It can sub six kilowatts of power.
That's every single ounce of power that
my house could deliver.
I plug my ears,
I close my eyes.
I turned on the power and I heard this
huge crackling sound as six kilowatts of
power surge through my capacitor bank.
And then I heard a pop pop,
pop sound.
As I blew out every single circuit
breaker in the house,
the whole house was plunged in darkness.
My poor mom,
every time she come home she would see
the lights flicker and die and she must
have wondered,
why couldn't I have a son who plays
baseball?
Why can't he learn basketball and for
God's sake,
why can't you find a nice Japanese girl?
I mean,
why does he have to build these machines
in the garage?
Well,
these machines that I built in my garage
earn the attention of a physicist,
Edward Teller,
father of the hydrogen bomb,
and he arranged for me to get a
scholarship to Harvard and my career got
a headstart.
He knew exactly what I was doing.
I didn't have to explain to him that I
was experimenting with anti matter.
I was creating anti electrons and my
mom's garage and using atis measures to
eventually create beams of anti matter
and matter is the opposite of matter.
It has the opposite charge,
so an electron has negative charge.
The positron or anti electron has
positive charge.
This means that you cannot create anti
molecules and anti Adams,
anti hydrogen was made at Cern,
outside Geneva,
Switzerland,
and also at fermilab outside Chicago
where have anti electrons circulating
around antiprotons and in Brookhaven
national laboratory,
Long Island.
Just recently,
they detected anti helium.
We have two antiprotons with two anti
neutrons to create anti helium for every
piece of matter.
There's a counterpart which is made out
of antiemetic,
and when the two collide,
by the way,
that releases the greatest energy source
in the universe,
it is 100 percent conversion of matter
to energy by Einstein's equations.
E equals MC squared.
Inside the nucleus of the atom,
we have particles upon particles when
you smashed them apart.
The 19 fifties,
we were drowning in subatomic particles.
In fact,
J dot Robert Oppenheimer,
the father of the atomic bomb,
once made a statement,
he declared that the Nobel Prize in
physics should go to the physicist who
does not discover a new particle this
year.
That's how many particles were being
discovered.
So let's talk about the particles zoo.
Right now we've physicists have unlocked
hundreds,
thousands of subatomic particles,
and we've been able to piece them
together.
A jigsaw puzzle is called the standard
model.
It has 36 quarks,
19 free parameters,
three generations of Clarks,
no rhyme,
no reason,
but this is the most fundamental basis
of reality that we've.
Businesses have been able to construct
billions of dollars,
20 Nobel prizes have gone into the
creation of the standard model and it is
the ugliest theory known to science,
but it works.
There's one piece missing and that one
piece that's missing is called the Higgs
Boson.
We expect to find it.
We want to create a higher version of
this theory and that theory we think is
string theory.
String theory is based on the simple
idea that all the four forces of the
universe,
gravity,
electromagnetic force,
and the two nuclear forces can be viewed
as music.
Music of tiny little rubber bands.
So if I had a supermarket scope and I
could look right into the heart of an
electron,
what would I see?
I would see a vibrating rubber band and
if I trying it,
it turns into a neutrino.
I trying it again,
it turns into a court I trying and again
turns into a Yang Mills particle.
In fact,
by playing it enough times,
I get thousands of subatomic particles
that have been catalog patiently by
businesses.
String theory we think is a theory of
everything now in string theory in turn
can be summarized in an equation about
an inch long.
That's my equation.
This is called string field theory and
how will we test it?
We are building a machine,
the biggest machine of science ever
built in the history of the human race
outside Geneva,
Switzerland.
It is the large Hadron collider.
Some of the Higgs Boson we think will be
created by the large hadron collider,
a tube 17 miles.
It's a conference with two beams of
protons circulating in opposite
directions,
then slamming together,
creating a shower of particles and among
these particles we hope to find the
expose on,
but not only that,
we helped to find particles even beyond
the higgs on the next set of particles
beyond the higgs on our spa articles.
The next layer of the jigsaw puzzle are
called particles.
Super particles,
nothing but higher vibrations,
higher musical notes of a vibrating
string,
and what else could we do?
We can also unlock the secrets of the
Big Bang.
You see Einstein's equations breakdown
at the instant of the Big Bang and the
center of a black hole.
The two most interesting places in the
universe are beyond our reach.
Using Einstein's equations.
We need a higher theory and that's where
a string theory comes in.
String theory takes you before the big
bang before genesis itself,
and what is string theory?
Say it says that there is a multiverse
of universities.
Where did the Big Bang come from?
Well,
Einstein's equations give us this
compelling picture that we are like
insects on a soap bubble as gigantic
softball,
which is expanding and we are trapped
like flies on flypaper.
We can escape the soap bubble and that's
called the Big Bang theory.
String theory says there should be other
bubbles out there in a multiverse of
bubbles.
When to universities collide,
it can form another universe.
When the universe splits in half,
it can create two universes and that we
think is the big bang.
The Big Bang is caused either by the
collision of universes or by the
visioning of universities.
If there are other dimensions,
if there are other universes,
can we go between universes?
Well,
that of course is very hard.
However,
ours at wonderland gives us a
possibility that maybe one day we might
create a wormhole between universities.
This is a wormhole think of taking a
sheet of paper and putting two dots on
it.
The shortest distance between two points
is a straight line,
but if I can fold,
if I can follow that sheet of paper,
then perhaps I can create a shortcut,
a shortcut through space and time called
a wormhole.
This is a genuine solution of Einstein's
equations.
We can actually see this in string
theory.
The question is how practical is it to
go through one of these things we don't
know.
In fact,
there's a debate among businesses today,
Stephen Hawking,
many physicists are jumping into the
game of trying to figure out whether
it's physically possible to go all the
way through a wormhole,
because if you could then you might be
able to use this as a time machine.
So the string theory is a theory of
everything.
It's also a theory of time and time.
Machines are allowed in Einstein's
equations,
but to build one is extremely difficult.
Far more energy is required than a
simple Delorean with potassium.
You know,
trillions of years from now,
the universe is going to get awfully
cold.
We think the universe headed for a big
freeze.
All the stars will blank out.
Stars will cease to twinkle.
The universe will be so big,
it will be very cold.
At that point,
all intelligent life in the universe
must die.
The laws of physics or a death warrant
to all intelligent life.
There's only one way to escape the death
of the universe and that is leave the
universe.
We are now of course entering the realm
of science fiction,
but at least we now have equations.
The equations of string theory,
which will allow us to calculate if it
is possible to go through a wormhole to
go to another universe where it's warmer
and perhaps we can start all over again.
If you were to summarize the march of
physics over the last 10,000
years,
it would be the distillation of the laws
of nature into four fundamental forces,
gravity,
electricity and magnetism,
and the two nuclear forces,
but then the question is,
is there a fifth force,
a forest beyond the forces that we can
measure in the laboratory,
and believe it or not,
there are physicists who have actually
looked very carefully for the fifth
force.
Some people think maybe it's psychic
phenomenon,
maybe it's telepathy,
maybe it's something called power.
Maybe it's the power of the mind may be
consciousness.
Well,
I'm a physicist.
We believe in testing theories to make
sure that they are falsifiable and
reproducible.
We want to make sure that on demand,
your theory works every single time
without exception,
and if your theory fails one time,
it's wrong.
In other words,
Einstein's theory,
half's has to work every single time
without exception one time.
Einstein's theory is proven to be wrong.
The whole theory is wrong.
Well,
so far we can reproduce these four
physical theories,
but at fifth theory cannot be
reproduced.
We've looked for it.
Some people think that maybe a fifth for
is maybe short range like not over the
nucleus of the atom,
but ranging over several feet and we
can't find any.
We physicists in the last 10 years I've
discovered a new energy source larger
than the galaxy itself.
Dark energy realized that our universe
today,
73 percent of our universe,
the matter energy,
73 percent is in the form of dark
energy,
the energy of nothing.
That's what's blowing the galaxies
farther and farther apart.
That's the energy of the Big Bang
itself.
Kids asked the question,
if the universe banged that,
what made it bang?
And the answer is dark energy.
Seventy three percent of the universe is
energy is energy.
Twenty three percent is dark matter.
Dark matter is invisible matter.
If I held it in my hand,
it would go right through my hand.
It holds the galaxy together.
Twenty three percent of the universe is
dark matter.
Stars made out of hydrogen and helium
make up four percent of the universe,
and then what about us?
We the higher elements we made out of
oxygen,
carbon,
nitrogen,
constant iron.
We make a point,
oh,
three percent of the universe.
In other words,
we are the exception.
The universe is mainly made out of dark
energy.
matter.
Overwhelming the stars,
overwhelming the galaxies.
In fact,
now what is dark matter which makes up
23 percent of the universe.
No one knows.
String theory gives us a clue,
but there's no definitive answer.
So in other words,
for you young aspiring businesses out
there in the audience,
you may be saying to yourself right now,
why should I go into physics?
Because you guys already have a
candidate for the unified field theory,
right?
Just realize that every single physics
textbook is wrong.
Every single physics textbook on the
Earth says that the universe is mainly
made out of atoms,
right?
There it is.
The universe is mainly made out of atoms
wrong,
and the last 10 years we have come to
the realization that most of the
universe is dark and there's a whole
shelf full of Nobel prizes for the young
people who can figure out the secret of
dark matter and dark energy.
Let me get some advice to you.
If you are a young physicist,
perhaps just getting out of high school,
you have dreams of being.
Einstein have dreams of working on
string theory and stuff like that,
and then you hit freshman physics.
Let me be blunt.
We physicists flunk.
Most students taking elementary physics
and we're more or less encouraged to do
so by the engineering department.
We don't want to train engineers who
make bridges that fall down.
We don't want to create engineers that
create skyscrapers that fall over.
There's a bottom line.
You have to know the laws of mechanics,
so before you can work with the laws of
Einstein,
you have to look with the laws of
friction,
levers,
pulleys,
and gears.
As a consequence,
we have a very high flood God right in
elementary physics,
so if you're a young physicist
graduating from high school with stars
in your eyes and you encounter freshmen
physics for the first time,
watch out if you have a rough time.
That's the way it is.
I started out my life as an experimental
physicist.
Then I went to Harvard and then I talked
to my advisor,
one of the world's greatest experimental
physicist,
professor pound,
and he told me that maybe it's time to
give it a rest.
He said to me,
your skills are much better suited to
what you love the most,
which is theory,
mathematics,
the world of higher dimensions,
and I realized that he was probably
right.
The thing about physics or even science
that really intrigues me the most is to
find the most fundamental basis for
everything.
Rather than trying to massage a theory
or make a theory prettier,
why not find out why it works,
what makes it tick,
and so what I do for a living,
I'm a theoretical physicist.
Thank you very much.